a catalyst speeds up a reaction by
lowering the activation energy
and there are many types of catalysts
and first we're going to look at enzymes
which are
biological catalysts let's say that this
represents
our enzyme and the place where the
reaction
occurs is called the active site of the
enzyme so
right in here let's say this is our
active site and then the substance
that reacts at the active site is called
the
substrate so this uh this little picture
here with two triangles together that's
the substrate for our reaction
in the next step the substrate binds to
the enzyme at the active site and when
the substrate binds the substrate can
produce
changes in the shape of the active site
that allow for better binding
so on the left here we can see how the
shape of the active site
changes slightly when the substrate
binds to it
this formation of the enzyme substrate
complex is called the
induced fit model the substrate
interacts with the enzyme through
non-covalent interactions in the active
site so
things like hydrogen bonding or
dipole-dipole interactions
perhaps some of these non-covalent
interactions cause a shift in electron
density which make it easier
to reach the transition state for the
reaction
therefore lowering the activation energy
and speeding up
the overall reaction next let's say the
bond between
the two triangles breaks and we get our
two products here so two individual
triangles
and the enzyme active site goes back to
the original
shape and it's ready to catalyze another
reaction
next let's talk about a homogeneous
catalyst which is a catalyst that's
present in the same phase
as the reactants in a reaction mixture
so let's look at the hydrolysis of
sucrose to turn into glucose and
fructose this reaction can be catalyzed
by the hydronium ion
h3o plus and since sucrose our reactant
is an aqueous solution and so is the
hydronium ion
we can say that the hydronium ion is is
a homogeneous catalyst and it's a source
of protons to catalyze
this hydrolysis reaction here's a
drawing of the sucrose molecule which is
which is a disaccharide composed of two
monosaccharides glucose is over here in
the left and fructose is over here on
the right
and these two monosaccharides are joined
by an ether linkage
so we can see we can see this this
connection here
all right this oxygen in between our two
monosaccharides is an ether linkage
and ethers are fairly non-reactive
since ethers are generally unreactive
the hydrolysis of sucrose is a pretty
slow reaction and to speed it up we need
to add an
acid catalyst so if we add an acid
catalyst and we have hydronium ions
in aqueous solution a lone pair of
electrons on the oxygen
on the ether will take this proton and
these electrons move in
to form water protonation of the oxygen
gives the oxygen a plus one formal
charge and allows an acid-catalyzed
mechanism to proceed
and there are more steps to the
mechanism but ultimately sucrose is
broken down to form
glucose and fructose in this
acid-catalyzed hydrolysis
of sucrose honeybees actually have the
enzyme
to convert sucrose which is table sugar
into glucose and fructose
and since fructose is sweeter than
sucrose
honey is sweeter than table sugar
a heterogeneous catalyst is a catalyst
that's present in a different
phase from the reactants in a reaction
mixture
as an example let's look at a
hydrogenation reaction
in this reaction ethene reacts with
hydrogen
on a surface of platinum to form ethane
now since the platinum is in the solid
form and our reactants
are in the gaseous state the platinum is
an example of a heterogeneous catalyst
so here in our picture we have our piece
of platinum metal
and both the ethene molecule and
hydrogen are adsorbed to the surface
of the platinum metal next the bond
between the two hydrogen atoms
breaks and we get the two individual
hydrogen atoms bonded to the surface of
the platinum metal
eventually these two hydrogens add
across the double bond
of ethene and form the ethane molecule
c2h6
so the hydrogenation of ethene to form
ethane is catalyzed by the presence
of the platinum metal